it's Monday
[Music]
[Music]
and some of you guys might recognize a
little bit of that riff right there and
I wanted to get you guys a gift since I
didn't get to talk to you on Valentine's
and that's that gift right there and
that's from tiny San who and that's that
magic man that magic that Pied Piper in
the distance you know he's that he he's
that Wild soldier who's just firing
arrows at us beautiful arrows from far
away and that's tiny sand whoo and he
sent that to me on my inbox for email
for Valentine's and he said give this to
the people and actually I'll read the
email right here he said eh yo sorry
about the tardiness hope this [ __ ] get
there in time just crank this out and I
decided to show some respect mr. John
Mayer - with a cover of his song another
kind of green and so that it is right
there from tiny sand whoo from me to you
Regulus here one more time a little bit
of that riff
[Music]
and that sound if you notice it sounds a
little bit like a pigeon trying to learn
to swim a little bit if you listen to
that you know I'm saying take that vibe
and as you're hearing it
you know it's got that a little bit of
that tinge if it's like somebody trying
to jerk you off while you're trying to
kind of hold your breath underwater if
that means anything anyone take that my
you here trying to hold your breath is
somebody trying to jerk you off a little
and now that he catapults this in the
time he gonna take us up that staircase
right here small tiny you could do a
tiny get big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I said tiny sand whoo right there happy
belated Valentine's and happy February
19th and and that last rift of our tiny
man he just you know when he take when
he really blows up there at the end and
he just lets it all hang out it sounds a
little bit it sounds like somebody just
putting kind of just lukewarm caramel on
their baby's back if you'll hear this
one more time take that NYU while you
get this there he comes in with that
knife
you got that jar and that's that creamy
right there
tiny putting that creamy on that baby's
back cream that baby up by put a little
bit of chunky on his soft neck spread
spreading this sweet peanut butter
spread that sweet caramel on to a baby
right there and that's that beautiful
hitter right there from tiny sand whoo
good to be back with you guys sorry I
didn't get a Thursday episode up but you
know what that's how life does it I had
a crazy week we're doing that we got a
pilot for Comedy Central you know and
I'm grateful it's a digital series you
know they're putting us on the digital
the digital network you know we're gonna
put it out there and it's based on the
podcast you know so it's you know it's
young dudes and and young women you know
and even maybe even people that's you
know in the middle people that's running
that dual you know dual sex citizenship
people that's running both operating
systems at the same time you know
transgender everybody's welcome on the
show and it's uh but yeah it's like
helping people get you know get tight
because we all running a little bit
loose I'm coming you from La Jolla I'm
down here in La Jolla California that's
went for a run
I'm here at the La Jolla Comedy Store I
want to thank everybody that's come out
we've sold all the shows out so far just
been to shows on Friday we got to
tomorrow down here with a little s son
and he is and he is Middle Eastern and
we also have another gentleman named
Jeremy Scipio who's a young black
gentleman both friends of mine and
Jeremy kind of has that syndrome where
it's like a white man kind of stuck into
a black man's body and if you ever met a
real you know it's like like if you if
they had like Death of a Salesman like
Jeremy would play Willy Loman you know
he's got that you know he's a briefcase
brother you know he's like that but both
very funny man we even having a good
time the show's already sold out for for
for you know the rest of the weekend
hopefully so I'm coming to you guys and
it's beautiful when the Sun is hitting
this bedroom
right now I just went for a run man la
jolla you go for a run out here it's I
mean everybody's beautiful they got I
mean they got tits and ass and you know
I saw a girl had a chin implant that was
a Lisa [ __ ] you know a small B Cup I'm
like damn that she got them them shits
you know them chin tits and she had them
and so there's just beauty running up
and down I mean my goodness you know you
just see all of it and people putting
you know slicker in her hair and gelling
their bodies up and getting outside and
letting people kind of see their skin
and you could see pets even the pets are
[ __ ] beautiful I mean even the pets
are damn I mean I saw a I saw I think it
was a Bichon or something or an
Australian Terrier and that thing had
some I mean that thing had some hit had
some hips on it to be honest and I don't
look at animals like that I never have
but that thing had some hips on it but
good to be back man good to be with you
guys you know I want to update you on a
few things we got the hamster rancher
video it's just been this bad this past
we got in get time to rest
you know booked too many comedy sets and
I was shooting a pilot all day each day
and then I had to take a train down here
to La Jolla and you know I'm grateful
I'm grateful to be busy but that
lifestyle is fast you know it's fast and
at the same time you know I'm trying to
keep my head above water and and I just
last weekend I forgot my medication at
home I don't know if anybody's ever been
without a medication but man you get
bent out the first day if I don't take
antidepressant the first day I'm okay I
don't notice it but that second day boy
you know they could have a bunch of
birds outside and all I'll hear I'll
hear like a you know I'll hear you know
I'll hear like angry like a angry crow
you know they'll have a bunch of
sparrows chirping and doing the you know
doing the Lord's verbal diligence but
I'll hear like a
crow like half a mile away you know and
that's what sometimes being off the end
of the Preston's does for me makes me
all bent out makes me you know just real
on edge you know like I'm what you know
like I'm just like I'm like I'm like I'm
living on like mice like my brain is is
living on it on the inline roller skate
you know this inline roller skates with
a this the wheels are in a row it's like
my brain is riding on one of those and
it's ready to just it's just wobbling
it's you know it's what it's wobbling
but so it took me a couple days meant I
had to regroup and I just hit that run
out here I got that form I'll hit her in
because I'm one of my goals this year is
to get that body pump you know some
people they like that old-fashioned body
pump you know you outside and you know
putting butter on the legs and pushing
you know going to prison just to you
know be able to work out that old kind
of that old school kind of [ __ ] but I
like that I like that you know you go to
the gym you get that maybe 70 minute
workout in and you get that full body
pump I like my whole body to feel pumped
up you know some people want that one
muscle group I want that whole body pump
you don't want to feel like my you know
my skin kind of lifted off the bone a
little bit you don't want to feel kind
of light in the legs you know I want to
feel like you don't want to feel my
balls kind of bubbling up by the top of
my sack you don't want to feel that body
pump I want to feel that warmth I want
to feel it inside of me
so yeah I'm down here in La Jolla and
it's been good and thank you guys for
your support had a good time in Portland
last week some people wrote in like do
what happened in Portland what was going
on and I didn't comment much on it you
know and then you know I thought more
about it and I'm like well some things
you know I should comment on and some
things I shouldn't comment on and the OL
and and you know I had a good experience
at RVs you know we had a lot of great
people come out a lot of people came out
I mean I honestly I want to put some
photos up I probably had 10 people that
came out as the
first time ever at a comedy show you
know and that's pretty amazing you know
just to have that that opportunity to be
somebody's inaugural experience but we
just had issue one night on the on the
stage it was just uh I think it was a
third show on Saturday or something
the emcee was just going through a tough
time and he and I got into some
differences backstage and uh and he just
you know he just said some offensive
stuff and then he brought me on the
stage and so it was just awkward you
know and I'm not I'm not but look I'll
I'll take responsibility like I probably
you know could have been kinder to him
offstage maybe I could have recognized
maybe if he was going through a tough
time you know I don't think I was as
keen as I could have been but yeah so
then it was just awkward so this dude's
like you know you know f-bomb this F
this guy [ __ ] do blah blah blah then I
gotta come out and perform so it was the
strangest thing I've ever been through
you know I've never had an issue at any
comedy club I've ever been to in my life
ever I'm trying to think of one issue
that I've had maybe you know people in
the audience being wild one lady bought
a snake one time down near on El Paso
one lady bought a rattler and let that
[ __ ] loose because it was her birthday
or something or you know her you know
her brother's quinceanera or something
they've setting it off and they let a
rattler loose at that club but outside
of that I've never I've never been
involved in anything at a comedy club
you know one time actually a long long
time ago me and a gentleman did get into
an argument he was in the audience and
uh and I got into the crowd and had to
choke him down a little you know give
him that light choked bra you know give
him that [ __ ] hard scarf you know and
the problem was while we're sitting
there wrestling on the ground
I had the microphone with me the whole
time so we're arguing fight and rolling
around and the whole audience can hear
every little part of it you know even to
the point where you know where you like
you know when a fight stalls out on the
- dude you're just like let me go look
you let me go I'll let you go look all
my hair you look oh my hair like oh my
you all right one two three boom right
and then everybody let's go the audience
was listening to all
that up close because I had the
microphone right there with me so man by
the time we stood up from that the
audience was howling because it was like
they were behind the scenes on a fight
you know they were behind the scenes on
a fight so but yeah that was the thing
that guys like [ __ ] you you know deal
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he brought me up and it was just you
know and I didn't say anything on stage
and I probably that's well I just didn't
want the crowd to feel uncomfortable cuz
it was all were it was really
uncomfortable you know and I know the
guys probably going through see you know
the dude it had you know he hadn't been
having a good weekend at all and and he
was you know he was opening up the show
and I'd asked him not to use profanity
at the front of the show because you
know I drop I drop some and I you know
one of the rules in comedy is if you're
too blue up front then it doesn't leave
room for the dude at the end to be blue
you know like if the first guy drops a
bunch of f-bombs then you know the crowd
might not be ready for all that and so
it just can make it tricky out of the
gate so anyhow that was the situation
and my blame and the dude you know no
I'm not but here's a crazy part the club
left him in the building so here's a
dude that was like threatening me and
then brings me up on stage and then the
club just is serving him booze the whole
time and left him in the building so
then he brings me off stage at the end
so when I get off stage he's coming back
up and I'm thinking is this do wanna
rassle you know this does this dude have
a dagger you know is he gonna try to you
know do we have a syringe of bleach and
he's trying to gonna try to get me in
the neck you know is he gonna try to
give me that ultimate white neck so it
was just it was just poorly run you know
I will say that and then and the people
that book you mean everything were cool
but it was poorly run and so I want to
apologize to my fans that came out and
we're in an environment that they felt
was poorly run because you know I take
responsibility for what my fans come out
to see you know a lot of my fans are my
friends
so I take responsibility for what they
come out to see and if they come out to
a show and the emcee the dude who's you
know is yelling [ __ ] this dude you know
I'll [ __ ] him up all of this [ __ ] and
the club's letting him stay in the
building because they're not paying
attention of their own stage because
they're just worried about whatever else
then you know what that's not it's not a
fair way to treat somebody and it's not
a fair way to treat audience members and
I feel like it at that point I'm like
and I'm not whining about it you know
it's like you know the dude was going
through a tough time I get it man we all
go through tough stuff you know and I'm
not even generally mad at the guy I'm
really not you know I've been there you
know I've been through I've been through
I've had a lot of anger you know and I
and I'll have all admit I had some part
and I probably could have handled myself
a little bit better with the guy you
know recognize he was going through
things but the club that leaves a dude
in there that wasn't cool it wasn't cool
so outside of that I think most of the
people that came out we had a great
experience
you know and that was that and that was
that but everybody's been asking and so
you know I wanted to comment on it I'm
not saying don't go back to the club I'm
not saying that they're not a good place
but I'll say that it was hella it was
the most awkward experience I've ever
had at a club over the weekend I will
say that you know anyhow what else man
let's get into what else I got that body
pump in and I'm down here in La Jolla
you know one of the things that happened
to me sometimes this used to happen a
lot when I was on the road you know
you'll get a couple of Muppets that I
reach out trying to catch that meet you
know you you know you get some ladies
you haven't talked to in a while and
they hollering at daddy
they see daddy's name on a sign a
dropping you know a text you know
remember it is I met you you know six
years ago behind the Mexican Grill
you know memory s you know you met you
know you used to know my girl Janet you
know we met about a you know we all went
over to the park and we're on a swing
set drinking liquor
you remember it is you know it's like
you gotta fend some of that off you know
I noticed as I get in this zone I got to
get a little more focused on my shows
man you know now when I was a little bit
younger I'd be out there you know and
you know a lot of these ladies whistling
whistling at this meat and a lot of
ladies trying to catch catch this hit of
ham in their jaw but now I'm trying to
I'm trying to stay focused I got my eye
on the prize and I just put an orange
slice in my mouth and I'm sorry I know
people would like to hear people eat but
I just put a beautiful little orange
slice in my mouth and got damn I think
was beautiful I mean I love oranges now
some of y'all know my brother used to
eat a lot of oranges more children and I
strongly remember I remember watching
him eat oranges and I just remember
thinking man that boy he's got it made
you know because my you know I was the
environment where like one of your
siblings would go off and get something
and then bring it back just for them
nobody was bringing back two oranges so
you'd be like damn this [ __ ] got
a hard shot it'll be Christmas you know
like damn look at this [ __ ] with that
Christmas orange and you watch them eat
that thing and you'd watch them you know
rip into the shell of that thing that
orange shell and just see some of that
skeet just fly out that orange you know
and that's just the Lord's back walls
flying out of that thing I'm just say oh
man you try to catch it in your mouth
and the air cuz you knew that was all
you were gonna get and you sit there and
watch your sibling eat something
thinking maybe to give you that last
piece you remember that be like Tammy
down the two slices left on this orange
oh I know one of these gotta be for me
and [ __ ] nothing bro nothing man
those are the old days man those were
the old days
but yeah what else ma'am I'm down here
in La Jolla it's beautiful if you
haven't been Aloha and you want to go to
a good place a lot of people come out to
Los Angeles and stuff too but you know
do holidays get that La Jolla in this
thing's fire man this thing is fire and
you know I didn't chime in over
Valentine's and I just want to express
my love man thank you guys thank you
guys for all your love and support you
know we had a call coming in about
Valentine's we're gonna get into that
we're also going to get into we had a
call coming from you know somebody
considering a a adult sexual
prostitution may be light prostitution
service work we're gonna get into that
we're gonna discuss what state would win
if all the states went to war which
could happen which states gonna win it
all
that's what I want to know and I and I
got some ideas and I know you guys do
too some of you guys hit the hotline and
as always if you have any thoughts or
comments from this week's episode you
cannot hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and
comment on whatever we have going on I
want to let you guys know that that's it
let's go man let's get into it this was
a call that we had come in about
Valentine's here we go today down in
West Palm Scotty Jay down in West Palm
and I have been spent time out in West
Palm and last time I was there one about
$800 at the casino there at the Hard
Rock Casino and also one of the first
girls I ever met off a tender I met down
there in West Palm and she ended up mom
getting married
years later onward wanted to give you my
story about how I almost died on
Valentine's Day back
Love Hurts brother he almost died on
Valentine's Day love hurts man that's a
fact Scotty that's a fact
homework died on Valentine's Day back in
third grade so I was getting a piggyback
ride one of my homies in the school
bigger black kid and then Jason whoa and
right there I'm gonna stop you ma'am I
mean piggyback ride least probably
least safest form of tribal after
Greyhound bus you got Greyhound bus and
then I think you go to BIC you go to
piggyback ride you know it's like you
know you got graham busing you got a
piggyback ride ma'am so this is already
out the gate he's dangerous you riding
on a brother homework I said let go he
didn't hear me I let my hands go he
didn't let my legs go and I smacked the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of my head I said
the only thing I remember most of that
our monster that day is waking up in the
nurse's office and then telling me to
ride my bike home okay I already got a
couple issues in his Valentine's story
first of all he heard you he heard you
say don't he heard you say let go he
didn't want to let go man because the
funnest thing to do when you're young is
to have your boy struggle and if he can
you know suddenly he giving you that
reverse wheelbarrow you know he give me
he giving you that dirty dancer you know
he's just holding me you know he got
your legs up behind his behind his rear
waist and he's dragging your hair along
the ground you know he's giving you that
free salon visit he's just dragging your
hair through the dirt and next thing you
know while your head hit the ground you
end up a nursing office on work my
brother told me I nearly I hit every
garbage can on our street and when I got
home I couldn't really speak much
English it sounded like a little bit of
gibberish and I couldn't open my head to
take the advil for my mom so she she
rushed me to the hospital and when I got
there I threw up everywhere immediately
walking in and they took me right back
inside Kerry so I guess the moral
disorder would be you gotta go to the
emergency room throw up as soon as you
walk in they got no choice thank you
it's not a bad thought puke as you enter
I mean I could work for a lot of places
you know just a you stepmothers house
your aunt in-law any of those places man
puke as you enter so yeah ma'am yeah
honestly I don't sound like that [ __ ]
bad dude you know people get murdered on
Valentine's people come home and finally
spouse getting you know holed out by a
big brother you know so I don't know if
this is that bad of a circumstance you
know you hurt your head in third grade
brother I mean it's I think I mean I
appreciate the call you know it's risky
piggyback
one of the riskiest forms of tribal
doing we all know that man and it's a
gateway also to homosexuality and I'm
not saying homosexuality is bad or
anything but I'm just saying it could
happen it could happen and that's it man
that's what's up there you know dude I'm
running out on this Beach I can't tell
you how nice it is down here in Florida
right now or I love oil I'm looking out
and I just see you know I see the trees
and I see the beach and it literally
looks like Florida
it looks like Florida man you know I
know and you know I don't worry I don't
want to get into it but my heart and
thoughts and you know and my love goes
out to all the people dealing with the
tragedy there in Florida and that's I
know that's a tough time and it's tough
to see that you know and it's I don't
know I don't know how you find a
solution you know it makes me what like
I've never been a parent but I just
wonder how hard is it to know if your
kids have guns you know if your kids are
not doing well you know maybe it's just
really hard to know you know yeah okay
yeah I mean cuz look you can argue the
gun thing all day it would be great if
they I'd love it if they didn't make any
more guns you know I'd love it if they
made a you know if they made a law a lot
of times that we got enough guns you
know I'd like it if we went back to bow
and arrows and see who's a real boss you
know I'd like that action sometimes but
even more so beyond that it's just
what's you know how do we know if
somebody's okay or not how do we know if
a dude's alright cuz everybody says oh
we had that kid in our club we had that
guy in art you know and I don't think
the video games helped either when you
got these shoot-'em-up type games but I
don't know if that influences people I
don't know man but it's just such a
tragedy of just children going to school
and then you know and then and then
they're going to heaven and it's just
disheartening and this and then the
media blows it all out now everything is
a social it's a
commentary on society and it's a
commentary on immediately it's a
commentary on um on politics and I wish
somebody would shoot up one of these
news networks yeah there you go
that'd be somebody with some real balls
but I just I feel how I feel horrible
because imagine you know a lot of these
parents they probably feel as much as
they don't want you to probably feel
some sadness also for the shooter you
know for the kid because obviously
something was wrong with him obviously
he was hurting and I'm sure as a parent
you just don't want to see any child
hurt all right man I didn't mean to
bring us into that hole right there but
uh but it's a real thing
you know they didn't have that when I
was young and old thing I mean they had
kids do gun set you know I had a one of
my friends was playing Russian roulette
his brother and his brother but was
playing Russian roulette and
accidentally killed himself another
young man was playing I had a gun out of
the party and accidentally killed
himself you know I mean definitely when
there's a gun in the room I don't get
super I'm not the guy that gets
comfortable I'm the guy that usually
leaves the room if there's booze and
guns in the room and you're not like in
a hunting environment I'm out I'm out
because that's because he's usually a
knucklehead that brings a gun into that
type of environment but talking about
that and talking about what's going on
in these and making people mentally
healthy and then I wonder what factor of
it is like do people even do humans even
mean as much to other humans as they
used to you know like to is that is
there is there something there where
we're starting to just lose the human
connection we're where we weave you just
look at other humans and you don't get
that feeling that we're the same thing
anymore or something you know I'm
talking about something in the air and
the zeitgeist just that we're not that
connectivity isn't there that you used
to be there I mean
used to need humans you know there was a
time when you need it you needed humans
for everything
and now you can kind of not need humans
if you want you can go a whole day and
really not need any humans you can just
need machines they even have something
called life support
it's a machine you could just be on that
you know back in the day if you want to
you know some support you had to go to
an actual person having just you know
cheer you on hold your hand tell you
they love you now they got a life
supportive machine so it's just maybe
you know times are changing I don't know
I don't know man it's just a lot it's a
lot if you let it be a lot I guess but I
guess you know what I try to do instead
right now I'm just trying to embrace
this embrace what's going on embrace you
know the things that are exciting I got
to ride down on that train yesterday
they had a guy and I'm not gonna say
that this gentleman was a gay man but he
was being predominantly gay kind of an
older black gentleman dressed up and he
asked if he could sit on my lap and look
I don't want a senior to have not have a
place to sit down you know and I said he
goes I know this is gonna sound you know
crazy or surprising boy the Train is so
full I was wondering if I could just
kind of just sit right here by you him
but by like by me he kind of lowered his
his you know buttocks and his you know
upper leg on the my leg and I'm like
that's not behind me I'm thinking that's
on me and so I was like well I'll get up
you could sit down he's like no I don't
want you to not have a seat you know we
could probably make this work you know
just awkward man and then he you know
when it was obvious it was uncomfortable
for me he meandered down the Train and
found another man who was more willing
to get into all of that and it's I know
but it was a nice ride it was a good
ride it was a good ride so let's talk
about this man let's talk about if the
world if America was you know because
people are getting separated you gotta
keep them separated
that's starting to happen because places
are so different places live by
different ideals and what means
something to them things are getting
separated and I don't blame it I don't
think that the congruence that a lot of
you know there's this whole agenda kind
of thing that pushes this you know we're
all equals we're all the same but it's
but it's not the reality it's not the
reality and I think there's people that
just want that I think there's some
people that believe in that and they
believe that in that because their
perspective of the world is is that that
we are all the same in it everything in
their little world it makes sense and
then I think there's other people it's
like that's not what's going on that's a
great idea but that's not what's going
on and I think people are you know kind
of getting back to or finding things
that make them you know will start to
take pride in things that are more local
you know there's been more local news
has been watched in the past year did
you know that and that hasn't been the
case for probably 10 years I'm sure it's
been on the decline maybe 20 people are
just trying to get back to their roots a
little bit find things that are real to
them find things that they know are
accurate in their life and a latch on of
those a little bit more that's why I
think you could see the states I think
you can see an all-out state vers state
war and who would win where would that
start what would that even look like
what would that even look like would
your state have a chance what would that
look like we had a couple calls that
came in and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna pepper those in with my own
thoughts and ideas let's start off with
one of those here we go
hey Theo it's Chris calling from wall
domain wall domain and we I'm sure
everybody pulled a Where's Waldo on it
and I dressed up like Where's Waldo one
time for Halloween more than one time
before everybody else did and everybody
got onto that [ __ ] for a while I did
that [ __ ] when I was in eighth grade and
my boy tically Todd drank some gasoline
at the gas station because we're also on
mushrooms and he had to go home early
long word thanks for calling Chris I'm
just calling about your topic of the
state's going against each other in like
a war scenario and basically my idea is
main my home state would be most likely
to be successful in this situation
because of all the whole hearted people
here you know we okay you say amazing me
successful because of the whole hearted
people this isn't a bake-off Chris okay
this isn't recipes aren't coming into
play this is a war brother this isn't
who got the most pecans and their you
know in their basket wholeheartedness
ain't gonna help this isn't who owns the
most episodes of Little House on the
Prairie on cassette let's hear more
we have dairy farmers we have lobstermen
we have everybody out here so bright
y'all got milk and shellfish two of the
most um things that people are most
allergic to dairy and shellfish y'all
gonna have gout and diarrhea bruh by the
end of the first battle let's hear more
oh it's I once knew a lobster man he was
fishing out there and he was bait in the
trap because there's bait bags I go in
for lobster traps and he broke his
finger on that fishing boat he drink
himself gallon I think it was there a
half gallon of coffee brandy and he was
good to go it's their medicine out here
so it's you give our war force a little
bit of coffee brandy some half-and-half
milk from our strong dairy farmers I
think honestly we would succeed succeed
a would succeed is seasickness
you just you just name one man who broke
his finger trying to fish so I gotta say
out of the gate Maine would be out I've
been up to Maine it's a lot of people
growing their own weed arguing with the
cops and the cops are also at home
growing their own weed Oh Cass spent
some time off Islesboro island out there
john travolta country went and we had
dinner with Kirstie Alley one time when
I was a child a friend of mine knew her
and I tried to [ __ ] a chicken an
attic
they're who I was in love with who out
first and also hit a bat with a hit up
like a vampire not a vampire bat but
like a regular American bat with a
tennis racket so I've been through some
[ __ ] out there you know Maine is just a
bunch of unfinished houses a lot of rain
water I mean it's good people you got
the black bears that shells state bass
cot for this for the for the state for
the for the college University of Maine
I think but I'm gonna say this I don't
think you guys get out of that bracket
out of that northeastern bracket no way
uh you guys are probably the y'all would
escape to Canada out of the gate I must
say that from Maine you know New
Hampshire's right there with you guys I
think new you know I mean New Hampshire
I think most y'all's force would
probably be I'm guessing wholehearted
lesbians you know you want to talk about
wholehearted I'm talking about that
vitamin D a hundred percent milk fat
lesbians that would be a lot of that
work force that war force out of New
Hampshire and I think that HAMP right
there would I think that HAMP I mean
here's the thing that Maine does have
domain has a lot of people that are used
to living in the woods so you'd have
that kind of malicious style but y'all
are a lot of vegans do a lot of people
up there eating raspberries and you know
you know cultivated scabs you know just
bad granola it's a lot I don't think
y'all gonna have the energy to withstand
y'all know about a lot of roots and
stuff like that's you could live in the
woods for a while so I'd say this main
would beat New Hampshire I think you
guys are probably struggle against
Vermont and Vermont of New Hampshire
let's be honest they're really just the
same thing two people okay I know that
uh you know New Hampshire I think is
John Irving country he wrote a lot of
those books Cider House Rules you know
you got a lot of wrestlers and a lot of
rich lot of rich kids up there going to
private schools and stuff like that but
the truth is that's a great white north
a lot of people hopped up on syrup
sucking on trees smoking dope you know
you got the basketball team up there the
Catamounts I don't think that's gonna
hell you know they're super pale way
pale you know people look like they're
allergic to the Sun
don't think anybody makes it out of that
bracket now I think didn't you get over
to Massachusetts and I think
Massachusetts I think Connecticut
Connecticut would get their ass kicked
by Rhode Island I'm gonna go with that
if we're starting in this north east
bracket Connecticut doesn't have a shot
Connecticut's a lot of you know rich
people a lot of people from New York and
stuff hiding their money out in
Connecticut they got these really fancy
homes I got these rolling hills outside
of Hartford you know you got the British
out there it's basically British it's a
lot of people trying to pretend that
they're not British and they do look
British they've got these little rock
walls outside of their houses fancy it's
Richie Rich a lot of covered bridges out
there so I'll say this Connecticut could
stand back in these homes and protect
themselves with these with some
long-range weaponry but let me say this
man you get some boys out of Hartford
you give them a little bit of gas money
they take over that countryside I think
I think and then they're gonna but but
Providence I think we'll whoop
everybody's ass promise provenance is
wild Providence is wild I mean I saw it
do one time in Providence he was shaving
right and he was thirsty he cut his
tongue with his razor and just took a
sip of blood for his own thirst and
that's Providence I saw a dude one time
he had a paper bag man what mustard on
the outside of it spicy mustard and
that's lunch I don't that ain't lunch to
me but that was lunch to him and that's
Providence out there you know people
eating paper works so I think you
probably ever never you know you'd have
Rhode Island sneak in but this just you
know they might take Connecticut but
Massachusetts gonna take all of that
Massachusetts has him wild alcoholic
boys out there and Amherst a lot of
alcoholism he got Boston he's Patriot
fans but Lenny and then what's gonna
happen you gonna have New York in New
York City man it's not the same as he
used to be let's be honest you want to
talk about a place as low-key secretly
as gentrified as possible we're talking
about Manhattan it's a lot of Mookie T
mooks over there a lot of high rent you
know alphabet city down there on the
Lower East Side is the only place you
can even get a [ __ ] good Graham a
dope or anything or heroin or even you
know you can catch some good hookers
here and there if you want it but
outside of that in New York City's men
overall us it's not what he used to be
now you get out into the burbs you got
some stuff happening you know
Williamsburg Brooklyn those people
probably aren't you in a fight this
ain't like the Newsies back in the day
when Christian Bale and the boys would
argue over you know the price of
newspapers and what was being printed
these dudes nowadays a lot of soft cats
out there so you can have a lot of dudes
saying you know Williamsburg like like
you're reading Williamsburg in the
graffiti in the bathroom you'll read
like um you know Derek sucks dick but
only if he's okay with it you know you
read [ __ ] like that you're like wow who
cares it's just supposed to say Derek
sucks dick you know it's not Murray
nobody even knows who Derek is it's not
a real thing it's graffiti but they're -
they'll be - they'll be you know they'll
be trying to make too much peace they'll
be trying to make too much peace in a
war they won't realize it's called a war
and they'll be trying to do all this
peace stuff and wear all these fancy
sneakers and I think New York has taken
out I think New York is taken out New
York City I think they get taken out
though by the real hitters Rochester
Buffalo Albany they had a guy on a
Greyhound bus out there outside of
Albany cut another man's head off at a
rest area
do you know the savageness have to be in
someone to take another man's head off
with probably a not even decent blade I
can barely go Peter rest area and this
man is doing upper body work okay okay
so I think New York is going to be going
in strong but it's gonna be a lot of
them real boys out of Buffalo Rochester
you know out of Binghamton you know it's
gonna be a lot of real boys coming up
there out of Syracuse not the people
that go to the college but the people
that live in the town you know I'm
talking about people with neck tattoos a
lot of blue breaths a lot of real cats
out there a lot of people that got some
you know a lot of people that have
tattoos of other family members on their
body gang gang
that's at Northeast I think you got in
New York but I think a lot of it and
then you got New York in Massachusetts
and I think New York gets that New York
gets that because they just have so many
more little pockets and hidden people in
Boston they tough but also Boston's got
a lot of you know hidden waspey whatever
you know fancy pants you know it's a lot
of you know the gateway city of called
the river of colleges all of this it's a
lot of muckety-mucks you know not only
it's a lot of people who don't wash
their own silverware so I think that's
what you're gonna get right there and
you get New York that takes that region
so out of there you got New York
predominantly upstate New York taking
that region that's where I'm starting at
and and that's when I'm gonna pull out
of that main conversation Chris I
appreciate your call let's take another
call right here here we go
this is a Ryan and even though I'm from
state of Pennsylvania I'm gonna have to
say Hawaii would probably win the war of
the states just due to the fact that
they're so isolated from the rest of the
country out and they have the natural
defense system of the ocean around them
and I doubt the other states an advocate
develops Navy or Air Force so they'd
probably just be the last one standing
basically there's no one wants to go and
pump with them and they could probably
even negotiate with him boy over in
Korea and not borrow some nukes maybe to
use so I'm gonna have to go with Hawaii
wow I don't even think here's the crazy
part and I hate to say this I'm not
trying to be rude I didn't think about
Hawaii and the truth is probably nobody
did it's that secret state you know it's
that state where you get done counting
them all and you're like to him when I
forget and it's Hawaii and if you're
watching on YouTube right now it's
probably getting a little dim in here
that's because the Sun went down and the
lamp edge that I'm using in here isn't
super solid but if you're on audio
you're still good Ryan that's a great
point I appreciate that call yeah Hawaii
don't think about that you guys have all
the water you guys are gonna have
military vessels they're gonna be
sitting out there now in New York I
don't even give you guys credit you'll
have that you'll have a little bit of
that harbor but to be able to access
that harbour over there in New York I
mean you're dealing with a lot of other
country a lot of other you know you're
dealing with you know it's just it's
gonna be tight over there on the East
Coast getting out of that Harbor so I
think that Harbor ends up being kind of
nullified over there on that upper east
coast but Hawaii it's a four-hour flight
from California
so yeah Hawaii would probably become
this this all right you guys would just
be this safe place I think where people
with the fight wouldn't come to there
and it would have to be if you guys
wanted to go and get into the fight and
I don't think you would and I think you
guys would just be able to find some
peace over there on your island or
divide into you know go off into the
separate islands Kauai and you know
certain people with certain beliefs and
everything end up in those islands and
defending their own territories that's a
great point man Hawaii's gonna tie no
matter who it is all right let's get
into another call here that came in here
we go what's up Theo it's your boy Brian
from Bonita Springs Florida again hey
Brian thanks for calling in from Bonita
Springs and I've been down there one
time I don't remember what I was doing
but I also remember trying to make love
to a woman that worked at a was that
place called it was a bakery Baker's
rack I'm not sure onward
man I'm calling about if all the states
started fighting each other in the war
man I want to say Florida would win but
we're out here sleeping a lot of people
there on them pills out here so I really
don't think Florida would even be even
in the top 20 oh yeah that's dilaudid
country you get out there in the mid
Florida man you don't even know the
candy machine the candy machine got two
opioids in it you know you give a kid a
nickel and he comes back you know he
come back with a couple a little handful
of cinnamon opioids so yeah I think you
do deal with some of that over there Oh
word lets him more your call I think
Texas would have to win and you know
that's true
they got all them guns out there most of
the people they're probably drunk on at
least 16 beers so they'd be running
around probably most of them wearing a
cowboy hat on a speculation man and s
hat wear speculation and alcohol
speculation let's hear more I got some
Spurs on the back of a pair of New
Balances with a damn revolver on their
hip so I think they're probably already
ready for a war now the grooves you
there that I think I wouldn't be
surprised if Texas might already be
ready let's look at that Southeast
region let's take that into account
really quick okay so Florida you think
you got you guys might be too pilled up
but you have all those bays and outlets
to water you have all that water access
I think there would be a lot of
interstate war in Florida before that's
the problem some of these states aren't
on the same page enough people from
Miami they're all gonna leave and go
back to whatever original country that
they you know came from pretty much
Tampa I mean that's pirate country so a
lot of them are gonna get their boats
out and be ready to rock so you can have
that aren't you in that Navy right there
out of Tampa
Orlando those people are gonna fly back
to their original States you know
because they're all down there from
inste they're all just Instagram and
Disney and then you will have
Jacksonville Jacksonville is a bunch of
hard hits and I think a lot of
Jacksonville they might roll up to
Atlanta and Georgia and and George join
up with Atlanta so I think you'd have
North Florida versus South Florida and
who's gonna win that one I mean you have
a lot of guns actually from Pensacola to
Jacksonville I think you have a lot of
guns and I think a lot of those people
might join force Joint Forces now Miami
if you see in the first 48 they got a
lot of guns in Miami so I think I think
Florida would implode you would have too
many people fighting amongst themselves
I think a lot of these northern cities
Pensacola Panama City Beach
Tala Hasse Jacksonville they would
probably move off to join other cities
they move off to join Atlanta they move
off to
join mobile and then and also some over
to New Orleans I think you'd have Tampa
but also a fleet would leave planning to
planning to go attack but they would
probably start drinking a lot of
Buccaneers fans I get that cannon and
next you know they would end up in New
Orleans and join up with Louisiana so
Louisiana's gonna have a little bit of
an increased force all right now you got
Atlanta and this is I mean a lot of this
is where a lot of Civil War battles were
fought so you're gonna have a lot of
nostalgia you're gonna have a lot of
people selling like you know you know
Civil War to artifacts and like
autographed posters you know he you know
tonight speaking at the bar we got the
great great grandson of robert e lee or
you know we're playing glory tonight and
everybody come watch it's a fundraiser
you can have a lot of that now nashville
you got Nashville's pretty split it's
like liberal and conservative so I I
think in places like that you can have a
lot of you know dissension within the
ranks people that want to fight people
that don't and it's gonna be tough to
really put together a good militia in
some of those places Alabama you know
those people are gonna go have guns you
know I have a brother in law firm
elegant Alabama and he had on underwear
one night and he said how many guns you
think I have on me and he was wearing
just underwear and this man was bodily
unattractive he had kind of like cute
ears a little bit but bodily
unattractive and and he had two guns on
his person at the time so that you know
that's what's going on there
that's gun country Mississippi
Mississippi gonna do [ __ ] man you know
no disrespect but they can't even win an
SEC title really so they're not going to
make it pop Atlanta could turn up but
Atlanta if if racial tension starts I
don't know if that's gonna happen if
racial tension starts in Georgia between
black and whites then it might get weird
if people are able to band together then
Georgia could be a real force South
Carolina and North Carolina they would
fight each other and I think that they
would cancel each other out
because for some reason they have so
much just angst against each other they
wouldn't be able to make it out of there
Nashville I think that they would
implode they got the mountains
so when you got those mountains that
gives you a really hot that high ground
is crucial and that's what's gonna help
Arkansas you know but Arkansas I think
you know they're still trying to get a
lot of you know I don't think they're
still trying to figure out whose family
and who isn't family and there's still
too many domestic disputes over there I
think that they would end up fighting
each other more so coming out of that
South I think you're gonna have New
Orleans down there but they're so just
they're having so much fun down in New
Orleans you know a lot of the gunplay
down there a lot of the crime there's
black on black so you'd have you know
you'd have to really you know band
together and get a good you know black
and white militia to band together I
think for Louisiana to have a good shot
but I think George is gonna be your
power player Georgia or Alabama coming
out of that Southeast region and maybe
Tennessee but you know I just don't know
now Texas then we get over to Texas and
I'll tell you straight up
Texas is used to defending a border out
of the gate so they're gonna have that
ability out of the gate you know Texas
is used to defending a border so they
already have all that experience bang
bang so that's gonna be huge
Texas is a lot of hard-working show up
men and I don't care what ethnicity or
anything that [ __ ] doesn't matter as
much in Texas in Texas is about do your
[ __ ] or get the [ __ ] out of here and so
I think they're gonna bring that style
of play to this war and I so I think out
of the gate that's gonna whoop
Louisiana's ass they'll whoop Arkansas
there's actually a town called Texarkana
which is Texas Arkansas Louisiana it's
the corner of all three and that town
would just be called Texas town because
they're gonna whoop ass New Mexico a lot
of those people might head back to
regular Mexico out of fear so I think
you got Texas is gonna whoop ass around
there Oklahoma's a lot of bad boys and
it's a lot of Native American people so
that you know that's you're gonna be you
know you're gonna be dodging bullets and
ducking arrows that's gonna be hard to
do but I think Texas does that
I think Texas really really does that
now over to this West Coast then you got
Arizona Las Vegas dude Las Vegas
although they're gonna take all that
money and run off they're gonna be going
nobody's defending that place nobody's
even from there everybody's out of
Nevada everybody's out of Nevada Utah I
mean they're gonna be praying for
everything to work out for everyone and
and I think we'll all need that so I'm
I'm hopeful that they'll do that Arizona
you know a fifth of that state is
probably illegal or maybe a 12th or
something and I'm not saying that to
offend anybody I used to live in Tucson
Arizona I had a lot of friends there
that were not legal citizens so you know
whatever but I think a lot of that
groups gonna leave I don't think they're
gonna be able to hold it down so then I
think you have Texas in California
they're gonna have to you know really go
toe to toe at some point Washington and
Oregon will probably refuse to fight you
know they'll probably try to you know
have a cook-off or do something more
peaceful even though you have a lot of
cowboys you got a lot of bad boys out
there you know in Eastern Washington and
eastern work and a lot of real-deal cats
but I think that they're gonna merge up
in some other group and they might ban
together out there in the hills of Idaho
so now you got men up there in the hood
in the hills of Idaho men and women you
got families just holding up out there
and I think that'll actually just become
a group that won't fight as much as they
will just start to take care of
themselves but then Texas is gonna want
a piece of California you know just
because everybody wants a piece of it
but they're the closest ones now
California man they got a lot of hard
heads coming out of San Francisco out of
Oakland Hayward Sacramento the home of
missing people San Jose one of the most
peaceful communities you got you know
Los Angeles everybody's gonna leave Los
Angeles and go back to either their home
countries or their home cities nobody's
defend in that place San Diego a lot of
the military's there right but that
military's from other states and a lot
of that military is they're gone owners
you know so a lot of the military
they're gonna head back to their
original States so you got to factor
them in elsewhere that's why I think
California folds I don't think they have
the chance to have a ton
land it would be some huge battles but I
think at some point you have Texas
taking that whole southwestern border on
the north north side of Mexico and man
and I think that and let me look at the
Midwest really quick Wisconsin cheese is
amazing ingredient you can't fight on
[ __ ] K so you're gonna be all bowel
DUP you guys gonna be [ __ ] in the
woods you know that could be very
alarming
you know also slow other than Wisconsin
boys they big but they slow but they can
fight in the winter because they're used
to being in the cold Indiana where the
Ku Klux Klan started a lot of violence
out there in Indiana I wouldn't be
surprised to see them show up Ohio
they're in the national championship
almost every other year so you're gonna
think they're gonna put something
together
I think Ohio beats Michigan I know
everybody from Michigan is gonna say
[ __ ] no way they beat us but they beat
2-year football teams every year
Michigan and Michigan State so let's
don't pretend like it might not be
possible
Ohio beats Michigan Indiana the problem
with in the end is a lot of their youth
over there and like some of these
colleges and stuff there are a lot of
transplants Indiana University's a lot
of transplants so who's gonna hire how I
was gonna take Indiana you go to Ohio
taking Indiana Missouri a lot of
swingers out there a lot of people
eating at the buffet you know you know
Wiener in and of a Jean ER so I think I
think Ohio takes that you know you got
the Dakotas Minnesota could come down
Kansas Colorado Colorado now a lot of
these men they're living on land and
prepared to defend themselves what does
that look like if it really gets wild I
think a lot of those men they would band
together I think there will be I'll be I
think it'll be a faction over there in
Colorado so you'll have a group in
Colorado you'll have a group in Idaho up
in those mountains that's kind of that
northeastern group you'll have Texas
just taken over the southeastern border
you left Georgia you'll have New York
which is a lot of upstate there's a lot
of them business cats in the city though
they're out they ain't got the balls to
fight man
got the balls to do banking and then you
got that Midwest region
I think Ohio will come over but that
Midwest there so they don't like each
other so much that I don't know if
they're gonna be able to ban together so
a lot of them might fizzle out
you know Wisconsin you got a lot of cats
just and they're so nice Minnesota nice
you can't win a war on ice so I think
they're gonna fold
you know Minnesota would like try and
beat another place and then send like a
get-well card which is sweet but not in
war we're talking my war the Dakotas
North Dakota South Dakota they get
together but who gives a [ __ ] that's
still only about 70 people and Mount
Rushmore but that's just those four
people are made out of stone doesn't
count so you got Kansas Oklahoma
Oklahoma with some bad cats now Oklahoma
now I think you'll see Oklahoma band up
with a faction they're from the
Northeast so then that's what I think
you got man I think he got Georgia I
think he got Texas I think he got a new
you know with that upstate New York
they're gonna roll through Philadelphia
Jersey nah man this ain't uh this ain't
everybody doin test 200 and Decca that
[ __ ] ain't gonna fly it's not gonna cut
it you guys are done Delaware they'll
probably boat back to England they're
done Maryland's thuggish but Baltimore
is drugged out it's the walking dead yo
so Baltimore I think we'll be under even
though they got that mill but you have
that naval military academy so if them
boys choose to stand up and fight for
that Academy you could have a real
faction right there so that's where I'm
at you know that's where I'm at and I'll
finish that up on Thursday I think I'll
talk about it a little bit more about
what is it you know how does this play
out how does it finish out and if you
guys have some thoughts and you want to
chime and hit that hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
but I feel like that's kind of where
it's at and to me I've always kind of
felt like Texas would take it but now
that I'm looking at some of the
geography I think you'll just end up
with some separate groups here and there
and that would kind of become some of
the new
you know America and I don't even think
about Chicago you know I think Chicago's
is gonna be kind of this hub where a lot
of you know whoever wins that Midwest is
gonna take over Chicago
so whatever state that is I mean
Illinois I love they could do something
I don't know what do you think you think
I'm crazy
Hawaii sitting out there on the outside
man you make me want to move toll why
that's for sure that seems like the
place to be that seem like the place to
be man all right let's take one more
call here here we go about this about
this this issue hey Tim here from
Australia is this thinking about who was
gonna win the war between all the states
and Tim is from Australia and it figures
that Tim would be thinking about as
Australia predominantly criminals people
doing crime or people whose grandparents
did crime he had to do crime and end up
in Australia let's hear more
now you better considered like numbers
obviously you know good primary sort of
driver here so and gun ownership and so
on so Vermont first of all the fighting
men and women of Ben and Jerry's
division
they'll hold out for maybe a good five
minutes from very early right so Vermont
out or they gonna be hopping up Andheri
onward Montana great fighters yes but
only 1 million people up there I think
something like that they'll write this
one out in the hills you know don't come
back that was this they're not going to
be they're not gonna be on the podium
Louisiana now low population high gun
ownership good fighting disposition and
importantly ocean access so this isn't
just a land war I mean you know if
you've got ocean access you've got to
use it you're gonna have your boats out
there we go oh you're at home so they
might do better than you think
now we get to the big number States and
you think in you know New York
California which is sort of you know
Hillary voting people but you know New
York State is around 20 million I think
California 40 million so even if you
have a percentage of those people armed
and willing to have a go they might do
better than you think that's a good
point
that's a good point is based on sheer
numbers you know so say you say if you
have just 25% of 20 million and they're
willing to fight that's four or five
million I'm not sure with guns and if
you put them up against Montana and you
are on every one that's five million
against 1 million so those numbers are
gonna play a big that's gonna play a big
issue that's gonna be a big deal that's
a really really good point I might have
to make me reconsider some things
homework do better than you think
also ocean access this is this is
potentially a crucial aspect in the
great United States war of twenty
eighteen nineteen twenty however long it
lasts then you get to the beat dog here
take this and that's triple cuz that
ocean access you can if you can get a
group to sit out in the ocean making a
shoot in at another group they can bomb
in or they can just wait and let the
fighting subside which is what which is
what Ryan's talking about from Hawaii
it's just sitting out there out there
eating pineapples and you know touching
each other's [ __ ] you know let's
hear more being people all the oil all
the sources they can they can keep this
battle up for a long a long time and a
civilian population and knowledgeable
about weapons take this from our in my
friend and there you go and then it's an
Australian voting for Texas right there
and Australia had one fight I think a
long time ago and it was called
Gallipoli and there's a movie about it
where Mel Gibson got in a fight with one
of his cousins I think it wasn't a home
video I don't think I think it was an
actual film that you can see and it was
pretty good but that's it if you got
some thoughts on who would take maybe
take that next episode you know who
would take that you know is there
something I'm not thinking about about
one of these states because it I mean
look you never know what can happen I
mean crazy things have happened you know
could it happen is a you know and that's
another thing do you think there could
be a state will a state war looming am I
crazy are you crazy
hit that hotline man nine eighty five
six six four nine five zero three and
we're gonna get into a couple more calls
about other topics right now some people
called in and I'm gonna tell you guys
too that I will be at fantasy Springs
casino in Indio California this weekend
the 23rd and 24th of February I'll be in
Tacoma March 15th and 16th and Spokane
the 17th of March I'll be in Oxnard the
23rd and 24th and 25th of March and then
April albeit bananas comedy in Hasbrouck
Heights April 20th and 21st and
Hasbrouck Heights New Jersey and those
are some of the dates that we have on
the books right now some other things
we'll be getting in Oh Tampa I'll be in
Tampa
April 6th and 7th and you can grab those
tickets now all those tickets are
available through Theo von comm slash
tour t oh you are but yeah there's
probably a lot of tactical things I
don't understand you know about war and
fighting and that sort of thing and I'd
love to know if some people have things
that I'm maybe considering that would
really affect the way that that would
all lay down let's take a couple more
callers here man I I appreciate you guys
calling and hittin the hotline and we
will do a follow-up episode this
Thursday where we kind of chime in where
we put some of you guys's calls into you
know just in the response to the the the
states the war the states and in
response to some of this other activity
in Nyssa net alright praise God here we
go
hey do just wanted to call and had a
question for you because I'm struggling
right now got my old apartment got laid
off last Friday and I've been in the
dark arts for a while and for the last
couple of years since I got back from
overseas things have been good that
started off difficult and nothing it's
been going great and now that I got laid
off and I feel that pull and I was just
wondering
what you do in addition to talk to other
people you know who are like-minded
thanks for calling man
yeah when you get in that tough
situation that dark arts seem to be
sometimes it's that first line of
defense you know it's that first like
the first thing you think to do when
things are going tough is to do
something that's you know not cavalier
for yourself and not real positive and
sometimes it's hard it's hard when I
know like for example if I if I feel
like you know I'm doing a good streak
and no you know masturbation no no doing
no masty you know no doing no masty and
and then next thing you know you know I
found myself by myself and something
happens I have a bad show or I don't get
a job or I don't get on The Tonight Show
it just something it makes me feel not
good then I resort to I'm gonna sink it
off [ __ ] it man life sucks I'm a
jerk-off all over myself and I'll get
into that space but you know when I find
that those things don't happen as much
or when when I don't choose to go over
into those dark art avenues is when I'm
with other people if I'm if I spend time
with people that I care about then I
noticed that my brain doesn't go there
instead my brain will bring up the
problem to somebody you know bring up
the problem to a a loved one or a friend
or something say man this happened and
they'll be like oh you know it's
everything's gonna be okay and the next
thing you know I get back to a
comfortable square in my brain instead
of living out there in that wild dark
art Tetris you know where the squares
are just coming at you and you're just
jerking off so that's something that I
find is I is spending time with others
you know spending time with others and
there's other little things you know and
everybody does it different people do
meditations people go for a walk you
know people do little things because
usually that temptation arises and it'll
just sit on you for a little bit you
know the temptation to act out the
temptation you know
run around on your spouse oh that's him
too you know to flirt with a girl the
temptation calls trouble raise hell that
pull that little pull inside of you Oh
things didn't go well I'm gonna get
[ __ ] up you know this didn't happen
I'm gonna buy a couple grams of cocaine
and [ __ ] race rats out there outside
of the city limits where you legally can
and I'm gonna make them choices but that
usually that's just like about it's a
second about 30 seconds or a 90 seconds
that that real that pull is there and if
you can ride out you don't give in to
that initial pull usually things are
fine usually you can get through it and
get back to your regular brain and your
regular brain is uh you know it sounds
like one that's doing pretty good you
know like you've had some good things
going for yourself since you got back
from service but I appreciate your
service man and I appreciate you calling
in Austin let's go another call right
here here we go hey Theo I kind of
needed your input opinion on the fact
that I I've been basically propositioned
by wealthy man tangents and sort of like
relationship even before you like turned
18 it has been going on and I recently
moved to LA okay so you got wealthy men
throwing them bucks for them bucks you
got wealthy men offering that booty cash
you know they're trying to swipe that
card between you ass cheeks and it's
popular especially out here in Los
Angeles I think a lot of men also
there's this this whole new side of that
where a lot of men are just in fear of
being with a woman where there isn't a
transaction because then there's no
clear terms of what's going on you know
it makes me wonder if prostitution or if
you know legalization of prostitution
might be on the loom looming on the on
the horizon because men are afraid even
you know do regular sex or touch regular
local cooter I mean I get nervous I
won't even jerk off in the city limits
anymore I Drive outside of town a
jerk-off you know if you see me jerking
off out somewhere outside of town with
group of other men it's not a gay thing
it's just straight men trying to just
survive that's all that is you know I
don't come locally usually if I can help
it
because it's to the risk/reward is too
much in Los Angeles but I appreciate you
calling young lady
and you've been propositioned by these
men and let's hear more about it and the
concentration of this ring is at an
all-time high
I don't know it's like a curse or what
but it's something I have like always
been against even when it came to
personally my own aspirations and dreams
etcetera just not something I really
believe it okay so it's not something
you really believe in you know slinging
that canal out there to you know to get
to get ahead or to make a little bit of
cash okay let's hear more but right now
my entire family is in financial strain
going through a lot of hardships and
we've never been rich or anything like
that but it's just really hard it has
every single member of my family going
through this financial hardship and then
earlier today my sisters that it was in
a freak accident and in Puerto Rico home
damp were two Rico in this accident
country and if you ever had a friend if
you have a friend that's very
accident-prone I think it's safe at this
point to nickname him or her Puerto Rico
because you know they got bad moon
rising over there and they got that juju
hitting the air and that voodoo you know
gripping the people on word um I don't
know if he's gonna make it or not cuz
that I Lee still has no electricity and
it's just tragic because we don't even
know how we're gonna if my sister's
gonna get to go you know it's just like
a whole mess and I've just been
struggling with if you know this whole
you you know moral compass and you know
I would never do such a thing it's not
necessarily anything selfless I could
have been struggling with this voice in
my head time like wow you're not willing
to sacrifice your family because the
amount of money that these gentlemen are
offering it it would make a substantial
difference and my family's luck okay and
that's just where the call ends right
there that's it thank you for calling
young lady that's a
that's a conundrum that's a conundrum
you know I mean my first thought is no
my first thought is no you don't do that
but that I think is also an old idea you
know I think it's you know I've never
had that you know I got that decent dick
but I never had anything that people
really wanted real heartily and it was
coming to pay for it I never had that
pay for you know that pay for did I've
just had that you know get it when they
get it day and and sex is a commodity
it's one of the biggest commodities out
there it's pushed constantly in fact I
as I was jogging today I saw so many
tits and asses and breasts and you know
I mean you could see outlines of vulvas
and you could see trimesters you could
see everything and it made me think like
damn like when I was growing up sex was
what you were trying to get and now I
don't know if that's the case anymore I
think now sex is available readily
available and what you're trying to get
is something real something tangible
something that you know when you throw
when you throw when you throw it down
into your heart it echoes you know
something that makes a that reverberates
and so you know with that thought look
if you got to get out there and do it
honey you get out there and do it you
know I'm not gonna be mad at you there's
you know there's women doing it for far
less reasons that's for sure
and there's women doing it for real
reasons and I know it's a tough world
you know I know it's a tough world and I
can't you know I'd be lying to you if I
didn't tell you I'd let one of these
fancy producers maybe when I first moved
to town put his thumb in my ass for
probably you know 30 grand or something
maybe I would I don't know I didn't get
that opportunity you know I never I
don't give their I haven't got very many
opportunities in Hollywood but you know
I mean it's sweet that you're thinking
about it for your family you know and I
you know I can't imagine what that's
like to have families somewhere
struggling your sister's father that
part seemed a little wild to me as
sisters fathers that your father I mean
if a tree fell on him or something it's
not your father let me hear that part
again here we go
dreams of pleasure I just not something
I really believe it but right now my
entire family is in financial strain
going through a lot of hardships and
we've never been rich or anything like
that but it's just really hard it has
every single member of my family going
through this financial hardship and then
earlier today my sisters that it was in
a freak accident and in Puerto Rico they
don't know if it's gonna make it or not
cuz that island still has no electricity
and your sisters dad yeah I mean that
maybe that's I'm just getting you know
picky there with some of the facts and
whatever you know I'd like to see you
try to find other ways to get through it
but these days if it does you know what
does it mean to you
I mean is it mean a lot to you to sex
mean a lot to you you know if you don't
get I mean if it means a lot to you then
I think you find some other way to fight
through it and get through it if it
doesn't mean anything to you maybe
that's what you maybe that's the deal
you know and I don't say you get a
broker or something but I say you get
out there and you get some good money
you know it just seems like the things
are gonna come along with that
environment of what really scares me for
you
you know I mean you know people women
sell them that selling sex has been from
the beginning of time everybody's
selling sex in some form or another you
know a lot of these makeup ads a lot I
mean there's billboards in Los Angeles
say sugar models on every other corner
you know that while the whole time
there's this you know times up movement
there's also this whole other movement
where it's just sex is just become
an item for exchange and maybe that's a
safer place for it you know I don't know
I mean I think this is just another big
conversation kind of it you know are we
in a different time now am i living by
old ideals what's going on
am I out of touch that you know now it's
like about it's more about the other
side of things
finding the connectivity finding you
know making finding something that's
real when I was young is about catching
that nut Locker you know about finding
that look it's finding a little lady
that would let you you know hide your
route up in that nut Locker and now it's
changed it seems like now it's more you
know now it's even more like anybody can
[ __ ] you know you can you know get sex
here or they are a internet wherever
what else can I get something that
actually that I can feel so that's it
you know and I don't know if that gives
you some suggestions or not maybe some
of our callers will have suggestions for
that and I think that that's a big topic
that's a big thought that's a big idea
you know what does she do what would you
recommend you know I mean if this is my
daughter I'm gonna say no you know if
this is you know when people would even
say well that's [ __ ] up if this is my
sister I'd say but it's like Who am I
did you know I'm saying I don't know
what you know for my sister I would help
her out I would get her out of those
financial situations you know I would
say not we're not doing this [ __ ] you
know so I guess when you put it when I
put it like that to myself that it's
more family then it makes me really
question you know I don't know I mean I
just wonder if it has it really gotten
to that point where there's no other
option you know is there another way
that you can do it or maybe try some of
these other things I have these
different webcam sites or women or you
know touching their Vegeta's and all of
that and showing you know flash and
volve and all of that
showing tits and
you know breastfeeding babies and
everything on there for 30 $40 an hour
maybe there's something like that
available or or some other avenues I
just I don't know I mean the thing with
the sister important like what are you
really gonna do there that's not cool
like what's you know what are you gonna
make a couple thousand I mean I know
that can really help some instance but
how how long does that last in a huge
case scenario with hospital buzzerella a
weekend an hour
you know when does it I just feel like
you you know you you're really getting
into the dark arts and that there might
be some better avenues so I'd ask some
other people how to ask some friends I'd
ask some you know I'd ask around and
then I'd try and ask yourself really why
why you know you've gotten proposition
but I've been proposition for things you
know people want to sometime get me in a
ridiculous you know television shows as
I said I'm a good that [ __ ] in for me
you know I bigger thoughts a bigger you
know realms for myself that realm the
worlds that I want to live and I got
bigger circuses that I want to you know
fight lions in but then I have friends
to do pornography and that's their world
and they're great at it so I don't want
to knock what your world is but I do
want to knock on and bring attention to
that you healthily consider what's going
on and considering something from a
place of desperation usually isn't good
so that's what I would try and look at
for yourself those are some of my
thoughts and I'm sure a lot of our
listeners have thoughts if you have them
hit that hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three
I got another show tonight so I got a
actually crews and do that I'm sorry
about that you know I was just kind of
getting comfortable into this episode
but I'd love to hear some of you guys
thoughts and information on some of
these things you know my heart goes out
to anybody who had family and friends
over there in Florida involved in that
out in the tragedy
it just you know people make fun of
thoughts and prayers I don't like that
because what else am I gonna do from
where I am you know I can vote certain
ways I can donate to things but to think
about something and pray about something
I think there's a lot of value in that
as well I mean if the whole world
stopped right now
and was praying for something imagine
how nice the world would be nobody would
be doing anything except hoping good for
others so and you might be like what the
US a really hopeful idea and it is I
mean that's not gonna happen but it's
not a bad idea it's not a bad idea you
guys be good to yourselves may you
probably deserve it I'm gonna take us
out on this beautiful hit from tiny sand
who went that nice I'm gonna send that
in I mean wasn't that really really nice
Thank You tiny and I'll happy belated
Valentine's to everybody man if this if
this if this state war happens the war
the states who's going to take it hit
that hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three
[Music]
[Music]
there's a flip get that caramel out for
that baby back
[Music]
[Music]
this past weekend
[Music]